you say a writer should be writing every
day yeah do we always need to know what
the story is
hmm
I I always need to be writing a story
um I
I
I love being in it I mean it really is
my favorite thing
um
it really does
bring me happiness it doesn't bring me
happiness every second but when things
are going well and when I'm really
interested in a story and excited and
really eager to find certain things out
and how I connect one thing with another
thing
um
I I love being in it that's really like
that's really what I like to do with my
time I mean essentially since I was like
in my late teens
time has always been the most important
thing to me and when I say time I mean
time to write so I've always had jobs or
I've always made my living in such a way
that I could at least have maybe a
couple hours in the morning
uh like I worked for nine years teaching
ESL but I taught you know like afternoon
and evening classes so that I I could
maybe have a little time in the morning
or you know it doesn't work out every
day I mean but most days it does and I
yeah I just love spending my time that
way
um
I I love seeing
where stories are gonna go I love sort
of technical challenges I love trying to
write
different kinds of stories than I've
done before and
um
like I was saying earlier like the
improvisational nature of Storytelling
is just it's very attractive to me and
it's a way of dealing with both
difficult
parts of life and also joyful parts of
life
um recently
recently I was reminded of this um
Hasidic saying that
I read about
many many years ago in a heschel book
and it goes basically
like this
there are three ways that a person
expresses deep sorrow
on the first level
the person cries
on the next level up
the person remains silent
and at the highest level
the person knows how to make his sorrow
into a song
and I think when I read that
20 30 years ago or whenever it was
um I thought that's it you know like
that's what I would like to spend my
time doing is trying to
write songs and for me stories
have something in common with songs like
it's it's it's the thing that you're
trying to do
so that
your sorrow will have
a form
and
a melody and
I don't know I
um
I I stories are built on many things
other than sorrow
but to have a place for that when there
often doesn't seem a place for it in
real life
um is it's very dear to me like writing
is
it's really in many ways the most
precious thing to me
and off topic topics for a moment you
came to LA to be a songwriter yeah did
you read that in an interview a little
birdie told me yeah okay
so you you flew to L.A and I did I
bought a one-way plane ticket I was 18
years old
um
and yeah I wanted to be a songwriter I
already was writing songs they weren't
very good they were terrible but
um yeah and what style sorry everything
folk rock blues
um
uh yeah but I mean what happened what
that was
you know there's so many Talent talented
musicians in
Los Angeles and I was taking guitar
lessons from a very talented musician
and
I just I had to you know accept that I
just don't have the talent to do this
like I may enjoy playing music for
myself but
in terms of
you know being able to do this as a
vocation I I just don't I don't have it
and it wasn't that long after that that
sort of short stories presented
themselves to me
um in a literature class at a community
college and
it was like an immediate
match like I felt like I can do this and
it's very it feels very related to what
I was already doing but you know
I don't know it just seemed like
something that I I could be cut out cut
out for and
you know I've had a lot of losses as
everyone does
but I've fortunately held on to this you
know for all of my adult life and it's
been the thing that's giving given me
sort of a continuity not to mention
you know like this underpinning of
meaning
have you ever written a short story
about the music industry God
you know that first um
that I was telling you that the what
happened was
um
I took a fiction writing workshop with
Marilyn Robinson at Skidmore College One
Summer and she's the one that gave that
prompt uh write something from the point
of view of an unreliable narrator and I
had been writing a story about
a jazz pianist
but the story wasn't working for many
reasons and I had been working on it for
years
and when she gave that prompt
I thought aha I'm going to have this
jazz pianist
be the narrator because what I was doing
is I was it was a third person story and
he was one of the characters in the
story but what's really special about
him is in his mind and I wasn't really
capturing that using this particular
third person point of view we're back to
structure right like you have to find
the structure that's right for the story
not a pre-existing structure but the
structure that works for that particular
piece and once I realized ah it's his
story he's you know because he's he's
bipolar and he's his wife has committed
suicide he he's had a lot of
difficulties
and the story needs to come from inside
of him and once I understood that that
was what was necessary to tell the story
I think I wrote it in like three days I
mean it was
it was just very it was I knew exactly
what had to be done but
again if I hadn't spent all of those
years trying to write it in other ways
you know
it's paying your dues you gotta
just work at it and then yeah